- [Announcer] Please
welcome Drew Barrymore.
(inspiring music)
- Ahh! This is...
Hi!
Oh my God, Ahh!
It's happening, it's real.
Welcome to the Drew Barrymore Show.
It's Monday, my favorite day
'cause we're here to rebrand Mondays.
Boy did they get the
short end of the deal.
We love Mondays around here
because after obsessing over the weekend
about all the things you need to do,
I say, Monday's is the day to get her done
and look ahead to all the great things
that you can do this week.
(audience cheering)
(big sigh)
My heart's beating.
Okay, now, allow me to reintroduce myself.
You may think you know me and you do.
I am who you think I am,
but I'm also someone who
is learning all the time.
And I'm so excited to figure out
this thing called life with you.
I believe in the collective experience,
and for my entire life,
I've been interacting with people,
and that's exactly what I
want to do on this show.
This is all for you.
(audience cheering)
It's true, as it says in
the opening of our show,
we're gonna learn, laugh,
cry, cook, heal, all of it.
And I'm committed to
putting all aspects of life
into this show every day.
Now, here we are in this studio,
we have our fantastic crew.
I love you guys so much.
(audience cheering)
And look, in some ways
you're the physical audience
and you'll be hearing
them throughout our show
and hearing their wonderful cacophony,
bringing the life and energy to this room.
(audience cheering)
No pressure.
And we also have our virtual friends.
Hello!
(audience clapping)
Look at these humans in
this brand new technology,
but technology aside,
we found a new way to have
that collective experience
from people with all over
it, for all over the country.
See it's live, whoops.
So we'll see you guys throughout the show.
And to everyone else in my personal life,
thank you for watching today, I love you.
And to my two daughters,
Olive and Frankie,
everything, all of it,
is always just for you.
So, let's get started everyone,
and the way we're going to start each show
is a segment called Drew's News.
(audience cheering)
(van crashing)
(cat squealing)
(dramatic music)
Excuse me, sir, ma'am, guys!
Tell me your story!
Ma'am, I asked you a question.
This is Drew's News!
This is Drew's News.
It's Drew's News.
(audience cheering)
At this desk, we're
going to curate all kinds
of stories for you.
I am a news and pop culture junkie.
I love good news.
I also like odd or unique
happenings that make me laugh.
I love hearing about
trends and hot topics.
I like to seek out the stories
that may be a little harder to find,
but are totally life affirming
and necessary to hear
because we all need to
know it's going to be okay.
So consider me your human
scrapbook full of stories,
both big, small, and
everything in between.
Oh right. Our first
story is personal to us.
Tonight, the Empire State
Building is lighting up
in our signature yellow in
honor of our big premier.
(audience cheering)
Ahh!
And even though I'm a Cali girl at heart,
and I'm thinking of all
of you West coasters
during these fires, New
York is now my adopted home,
and this honor means so much to us.
Thank you, New York.
Now, let's see what made the papers.
(audience clapping)
Okay. Oh, I love this story
because it made her-story.
This year for the first
time three moms made it
to the quarterfinals,
Serena Williams, Tsvetana Pironkova,
and Victoria Azarenka.
I might've messed that up, and if so,
I am so sorry.
The winner was actually Naomi Osaka,
and I really just wanted to give it up
to all these incredible women.
Shine a light on you,
as everyone is doing,
and celebrate you right
along everybody else.
Thank you for all that you're doing
and inspiring all of us moms.
Our third story, CNN reports
that a 62 year old ball
Python has laid seven eggs.
Even though she hasn't
been near a male snake
in over two decades.
Is she 62 are 16?
Sneaking out for a little fun, uh huh.
This story resonates with
me because I haven't been
in captivity with a male
for quite some time either.
Uhn uh, I have my two daughters
and my cup runneth over,
if you know what I mean, I'm good.
However, when I usually fill
out medical forms and they ask,
is there a possibility you're pregnant?
I'm usually like, not a chance,
but now she's making me
rethink, and get scared,
and curious, and wonder.
Listen, this mama Python, she got it done.
And although it is
certainly suspicious how,
I say, live your bliss.
(audience clapping)
And finally, this one got me so excited
because I love board games.
I mean, literally this is my game closet.
There's no joke there.
And Toy Book magazine reports that Hasbro
is making a Guess Who
Hometown Helpers edition.
A version of the game with
characters like firefighter,
and teacher, mail carrier, and more.
Hasbro's also donating $10 per game sold
to community charities.
Does your person have
glasses and save lives?
Tk, tk, tk, tk, tk, yes.
One more story that I don't want to miss.
Actually, we've got two minutes to crush.
Oh my gosh, how did this happen?
Okay, so here we are.
It's our very first
show, and I am nervous,
I'm excited.
We're live in certain
places, so if I mess up,
well, you know what?
That's just going to happen.
And all I can say is, I am so excited
that we are here for day one,
and we'll be right back with more.
(inspiring music)